oh this is ABC for kids ABC this is what
I think it is heart attack was English I
have so many failed art projects because
of their show was he involved is some
kind of scandal in the future though
oops what they all I remember the old
books right yeah yeah yeah go to dreams
I was really jealous of these guys why
can't I more I like the pictures in the
books when they were halfway through the
transition so they've been mostly human
but then just have like a weird nose oh
if this is Brahm I'm honestly not
watching nice Brahma was a bomb run was
like the seven minutes you had to get
through so the rest of ABC kids would
start not true
oh my god the ferals about us the rapid
Ziggler Jana the cat they just love a
family fortune and they're never going
back and Darren the dark and that rabbit
mixing get the ride as they tell if I
federal TV ya know if there's a rack
called Radice he's a leader of the pack
there's a cat card MIDI cliana just keep
the finger I always like MIDI cliana the
best she had flawless style there's like
Madonna bras that she wore what he was
so cute and those evil guys were really
scary
they were always after not eat this is
not a heteronormative show he slept in
the same bed as big ears haha it was
very suspicious yes Joe of all time this
was everything I feel like this show
seriously prepared us kids for like for
my for life like 100% best show ever
made they need to bring it back how long
was it on vault um well it started in
like the late 80s it's great the Fox and
the lemon trees that I think I was kind
of haunted by this show like the one
where the seagull poop everyone got
pooped on by see girls they're all just
covered in it head to toes just Gumby
what trap door you're a fool if you dare
no no no
this was creepy like a chunk of snot
with legs again this is really iconic
but really weird mmm
so is he's just like a blob slave BTSs
that's probably what it was yeah
what was in that trapdoor I want to go
home and I want to watch them all rather
truces on Netflix I'm gonna re-watch it
all I can't believe you haven't seen
around the twist I feel like I've missed
out on a lot
oh you're getting these really quickly
yeah I watched a lot of TV
did you go that song you know why would
I want to go outside when I have this
great these great shows to look forward
to